meanwhile California Governor Gavin
Newsom he's actually trying to give 75
million in tax dollars your dollars in
California directly to illegal
immigrants Judicial Watch is now suing
to block that program in the Senate
leader McConnell is vowing to put the
brakes on Nancy Pelosi's insane state
bailouts here with more is Louisiana
senator a friend John Kennedy senator
listen I'm speaking out against myself
because I'm unfortunately I am tied to
New York because of this job otherwise I
would live there with you or in Florida
or in Texas but I'm here it's gonna cost
me money but what's fair is fair New
York well they elect the dumbest people
that spend all the money and tax us to
death Louisianans should not be forced
to pay for that no we shouldn't I think
what the the Governor Cuomo forgets is
how much money we've given the state's
already my state has received about two
and a half billion dollars already I
don't know how many billions New York is
received that may not be as much as the
governor wants but it's not chopped
liver
either our position on the the
Republican side of the city is look
we've spent 3 trillion dollars a lot of
that did go to state in local government
well let's step back let's see how it
works once the economy starts to open up
again let's see whether revenues go up
there needs to be a shared sacrifice
states and and cities are going to have
to pare their budget just like people
have now speaker Pelosi she won't
suspend at least a trillion dollars I
wouldn't be surprised if she's she's
working on a stimulus package for the
murder Hornet I mean she she she she has
no concept of deficits this is not
Louisiana ditch water we're spending
this is taxpayer money and we're gonna
have to pay it back and all we're saying
is let's go slowly and see what works
what doesn't work I think senator maybe
she should leave that gated community in
that beautiful mansion with all the ice
cream and even the freezers get on her
private jet make a big carbon footprint
get back to work like the rest of the
country and all the PPE math she needs
whatever she should be taken care of
like everybody else but get to work but
they want to use this fund their
unfunded pensions and their deficits and
they're dead all these are high tax
states that waste fraud and abuse if
it's not covet 19 my answer is no deal
under any circumstances help workers
small businesses health workers and get
the country back open that's it and I
think that's more than fair I introduced
a bill today to give the states more
flexibility to spend the money that
we've already given them and we've
already given them at least two hundred
two hundred and fifty billion dollars
but that doesn't mean the money should
be wasted it shouldn't be wasted on
bailing out mismanaged pension plans it
shouldn't be spent on people who are in
our country illegally I understand where
governor Newsom is coming from he just
thinks the border is a nuisance he
thinks that if you believe in
immigration laws you're a racist
I don't think it's that the vetting
people properly before they come into
your country is racist I think it's
prudent and the world we live in but we
shouldn't bail out that kind of nonsense
and I would point out a game we've
already given the state's an enormous
amount of money a ton by the way can I
point out senator and we always
appreciate coming on a program by the
looks of the background I would say
you're in Washington DC is that true
I am you're working well okay where's
Nancy my ice cream I'll send it the
expensive kind we're being smart
we're socially distancing we're wearing
asks we're we're there's a way to save
lives and save jobs and I said we're
gonna we're gonna work toward that end
we appreciate you working hard thank you
we appreciate it